[Music]
Cameron Mathison is here now with news
on Jennifer Garner look everybody is
rooting for Jen am i right I mean she's
done everything she can to hold the
family together after her breakup with
Ben and we have new inside as she who's
on your single life jen is quote not
ruling out dating in the future that's
what a source tells us about the 45 year
old divorcing mom of three actually to
be clear it seems both Ben and Jen are
open to finding love again but quote
neither one of them is dating anyone
seriously at the moment now to give you
a little perspective it's been nearly
two years since Bennifer split two and a
half months since been finished rehab 48
days since they finally filed for
divorce and over a month ins been moved
out of the family's guesthouse and into
a home nearby so how was Jen healing
after heartburn you can March through
hard things one foot in front of the
other one step at a time first it's all
about the kids Ben and Jen are committed
to co-parent it's so important that you
model for your kids how to make our own
little slice of the world a little bit
better jen is very zen going to church
every week with the family including
once with her mom and Ben's mom looking
forward at single life it seems Jen's
mantra is live with no regrets doing
like my life I'm not looking to go
anywhere that's right Jen you got this
now Jen is also very focused on work she
has Wiig filled with Bryan Cranston in
theaters now and she's got three more
movies on the way
[Music]
you